millions of fans the ideal man is this
guy country superstar Luke Bryan yeah
cuz he is crazy challenged at a best of
all well Luke doesn't take himself too
seriously even when things don't go
exactly as planned on stage last week we
had a wardrobe malfunction
after all these years of averting this
one wardrobe malfunction it finally
showed itself
[Applause]
[Music]
the fly was down down the zipper was
down so it wasn't his sexiest stage move
cuz you know Luke's got those down
stadiums I have to accentuate the hip
the hip thrusting yes and I don't want
to hit frust too much in an intimate
setting because it could send a
shockwave we were with the country star
and Idol at his I Heart Radio album
release party his latest offering what
makes you country is a question Luke's
been asking himself a lot these days
you said like you're less country now
there are obviously things about my life
that that are less country than they
were back when I was just strictly a
small-town kid in South Georgia what's
funny is is my success in music has
allowed me to even you know revert back
to more country things because when
you're jump-starting your career in
Nashville you know you're you're
scraping by youdo you don't have any
fishing tackle you don't have anywhere
to go hunting or anything so through the
years I've been able to to get more toys
so I can get out in the woods
oh gosh it's my lake yes I got to build
my Bass Lake that I wanted okay and it
has just big ol fish in it yeah it's fun
[Music]
you